let's talk about this story from the
Daily Caller House GOP will launch probe
into Biden administration's response to
Maui fires I would also just add they
probably need a response into the
Hawaiian government's response to the
fires as well as the Lahaina and Maui
governmental responses to the to the
fires because a lot of questions there
they say the house oversight and
accountability committee will conduct an
inquiry into the bite administration's
response to the fires which began on
August 8th and completely devastated the
town of Lahaina the federal response to
the Calamity has drawn intense scrutiny
from locals and the media who have
slammed Joe Biden's response so uh what
did he give him uh look at this people
flicking him off screaming at him
cussing at him here he comes after 13
days what do you do he gave everyone 700
bucks is that it yeah so we give him
originally they said that they were
going to give everybody that was
displaced both you know physically and
economically they were going to get 700
and more that was the original promise
to the people of of of Maui uh because
you know you got to keep in mind that 70
to 80 percent of Maui's economy is
tourism and originally the government
both the state and federal government
said don't come to Maui Maui is closed
okay so all these people lost their jobs
I'm over there
staying in a hotel in one of the the
biggest tourist areas in Hawaii and
there's nobody there it's empty it's
quiet there's so all these people
they're all they've all been laid off
and and then FEMA you know walks it back
and says well we're no longer giving you
money once the Press uh the Press
pressure went away they started walking
it back and so you know what people
there want to know is why why why does
the Biden Administration have to be
forced to do anything and seven hundred
dollars in Hawaii everything in Hawaii
is extremely expensive that's like a
half weeks pay for most of these people
and a lot of these people have lost
everything and you know they work two
and three jobs they've lost two out of
those three jobs
it's it's so infuriating to so many
people there but they don't want to
speak out because they're afraid afraid
of what they're afraid of of
repercussions because the I'm going to
be honest with you my experiences with
the Hawaiian government with the Maui
government
they're one of the most authoritarian
governments in the United States okay I
had a run-in with the uh the mayor of
Maui and I posted that video it went
pretty viral got you know uh like 15
million views or something like that
where I started pressing him and he had
his police force there put me in a
headlock so that I could not continue to
ask him questions all the other media
were allowed to ask him questions I was
not allowed to because I was asking
tough questions
he they do not want to be held
accountable they are afraid of looking
bad because these politicians they these
are their goals here it's to get elected
stay elected and get elected to higher
office what were you asking him I was
asking him what what was going on they
know okay they found 115 cadavers at
this point they know how many of them
are children and I had uh I I had
experts that were coming to me and
telling me like Pathologists that were
saying it's very easy to identify if you
find a a corpse you can identify whether
or not that was a child you can go back
2 000 years and be able to identify
whether or not that corpse was a child
they're hiding that number because
they're protecting their own butts
that's all they're doing there's two up
one to two thousand people quote missing
right but it's been like two weeks I
mean it's not the Assumption just to say
those people are dead so I went there I
was there for uh 13 days okay that
number went from 110 it's now at 115.
the death rate yes and now we're talking
you know there's still you know between
800 it depends on what list you're
looking at you know 800 to 1 000 plus
people that are missing okay
where are they when are we going to
declare
you know other people dead I mean yeah
exactly that's an intense heat bodies
melt Yep this is well there'd be
skeletons I worked at Ground Zero well
the bones melt I was working at Ground
Zero and the firemen would come in at
911 I worked there after the cleanup and
the firemen would come in it was so hot
under the pile molten steel flowing and
they'd be like yo they think we're gonna
find bodies they find Wet twizzlery
substance that's all that's left over
sure and if there's a fireman jacket you
know it was a fireman because that's
heat resistant and they'll wrap it up in
a flag but that's it that's all you find
in the rest of it's liquefying and going
into the East River sure and it might be
but here's the thing that they're doing
they are hiding information that they
have because they're waiting for it to
go away they want the media to go away
because the media can only stay there
for so long right it's very expensive to
stay in Hawaii so uh if it turns out
that 2 000 people burn to death because
government didn't give the water like
this I've heard and you confirmed it
before the show but tell me about it
that people within the Hawaiian
government the Maui government
withheld the water from the fire
department so they could not put the
fire out right because you know their
whole thing out there it look the
Hawaiian government the Maui government
they're they're very liberal okay it's
it's one of the most liberal states in
the U.S you think California's liberal
Hawaii is two steps to the left from
there I mean it's crazy and so you know
we're talking about
one of the reasons that the fire got so
bad is because they don't do any sort of
fire management out there it's because
they want it to be natural just as the
land you know as it was before that's
that's the government you have all these
people lobbying the government for that
reason we're not talking residents we're
talking environmental groups that have a
lot of power out there uh and so they're
they're diverting water away from these
towns and so you have people that were
more than capable even firefighters that
lived in Lahaina that were unable to put
the fires out in their own houses
because there was no water there wasn't
enough water that was being sent to
Lahaina and so you have firefighters
that are on scene that can't do anything
at all they can't put out the fires they
have no ability I heard us I've heard
this rumor going around a lot of people
talking about it that they set up a
roadblock to get out yes and people were
turned around to go back into the fires
but some people just broke through the
barricade and ignored it those are the
ones that survived is that true that is
100 True wow that is why you see the the
videos of on Front Street that is the
main road and it you know just being in
Lahaina for uh you know 10 days I was on
the ground there you there's one Road in
one road out okay you if they're
blocking that road you're not going
anywhere why were they blocking it they
were because there were down power lines
okay but here's the thing you have
Hawaiian Electric coming out now Maui
county is suing Hawaiian Electric saying
that their power lines sparked the fire
okay whether or not that's true is you
know a different argument but
when the roads were blocked the Maui
County government was saying that the
power lines were electrified okay that's
why they couldn't let anybody through
that's their claim now when Hawaii
electric is saying oh yeah no they
weren't electrified at that point
there's no reason that these people
couldn't have gone through
so but the people that did break through
the barricades and drove over those
lines they didn't have any sort of
effect from it the effect that they had
was that they survived the other people
burned in an Inferno and wow you know so
it sounds like the government's making a
false claim that the power lines were
active so there's a barricade what was
the barricade do you know so I mean they
had cops that were blocking the road but
at a certain point the fire got so bad
those cops had to flee too right yeah
well so when but the people that were
near the end of the barricade are you
know closest to the end of that crew
they were able to
um it was blocked all the way through
the fire actually but they were far
enough away the cops were far enough
away that you know the people that were
closer to the front of the line they
ended up uh surviving the fire it was
the people that because the line was so
long yeah that it's it's it's a two-lane
road going all the way all the way back
the people that were near the center are
there buildings on both sides of the
road or is there access to water so this
one so all the roads were blocked let's
make that clear but the the Front Street
which is the main road there in Lahaina
that one was blocked as well that is the
main road I'm saying to the right water
on the so if you're driving out of the
town you had water on the left side so
people I'm assuming got out of their
cars and jumped into the water some of
them were bailing but some of them that
were bailing into the water also died
because it was too late the fire was
already engulfing these buildings we had
a lot of wind yeah and that fire was
Crossing into the water a lot of people
don't realize
how hot fire is no joke obviously you've
had a campfire and you felt the Heat
stand in front of a building fire and
the fire can extend a hundred plus feet
and it's you're like whoa and you're
backing up right when I was I told the
story about when I was in Ferguson
driving down the road seriously like 100
feet away from a burning building and
inside the car with the windows up it
felt like my face was in front of a a
campfire and I was like damn like we
gotta move that's too hot it's crazy and
this we're talking 80 mile an hour winds
that are right blowing the heat into you
people you you're saying people burn to
death in their car waiting to get out
yeah and held at a stop by the police
and they burned to death while they were
waiting absolutely yeah that's exactly
what happened and that's why they don't
want to talk about this that is why
they're trying to brush this all under
the rug because there were so many
people that died in their cars there are
children that were found
in like car seats in the car very young
children that were burned to death they
found the cadavers and you know that is
a that's infuriating the people
especially residents that were there
like their children
were killed because they were burned to
death because the government is totally
inept on every single level we do have a
super chat Jack Fox is saying bones
don't melt or burn after a person has
cremated they're put into a what is it
what it says uh they're put into a
machine that pulverizes them into dust
wow I've never I've never I don't know
someone in fact actually they soften man
look it up this reminds me of Uvaldi
where the cops wouldn't let their people
go in to save their own kids and they're
like no you can't it's too dangerous
we're gonna make we're gonna not go in
at all what in the look you at some
point get out of the way they don't
bones don't burn during cremation is
what I'm seeing wow look at that yeah
and these people I'm telling you right
now so one of the biggest things that
happened here you know first of all
blocking the roads I'm sorry if I'm a
cop and I see an inferno that is about
to come incinerate
hundreds of people that are trying to
drive down the road I'm sorry I don't
care what the commander is saying I'm
moving out of the way well these but
these cops are evil they thought there
was an electrified power lines they
actually were probably giving bad
information
I don't care you drive over a a live
power line so I don't know if you're
you're fine I'm sorry if they're gonna
they're gonna survive that more than
they're gonna uh survive at Inferno I
mean I'm sorry I'm gonna let you do what
you want to do if you want to drive
around in the grass people were able to
do that drive around in the grass I'm
not gonna stop you
uh and you know a lot of these cops they
are now still simping for the County
government and it's crazy it's like do
these people they have no shame what is
it at some point you have to not a
single Maui cop has come out and spoken
out against
uh what happened they probably have
immense guilt that they murdered those
people absolutely yeah and people need
to be in jail for this people absolutely
need to be in jail well especially the
Maui Emergency Management uh
administrator okay because this is the
guy that decided that he wasn't going to
turn on any of the sirens he was going
to uh he said that if we turned on the
sirens and people were gonna come out of
their houses and they were gonna run
uphill into the fire I'm sorry but I
don't believe that the people of Ohio
were stupid enough to walk out of their
houses and run into a burning Inferno
I'm sorry I love the sirens at all if
not to worn about fire right if you go
on Hawaii uh the Hawaiian government's
website you will see that it says uh the
sirens are multi-purpose they're
supposed to be used for damn brakes
terrorist attacks wildfires uh tsunamis
all of this stuff I mean there's a
laundry list of things so based
basically what they did he got up there
and lied okay so if if anything he's
guilty of negligent homicide
okay because it was his decision that
ended up killing all of these people all
these these elderly folks and children
the adults that lived in the town like
the parents uh because I said they work
two and three jobs they're outside of
the town they work in the tourism
industry so they're way outside of the
Town they're in other parts of Maui and
you know uh it's you know probably 45
minutes away that's where a lot of them
work so they couldn't get back there in
time especially because the roads were
blocked I I I I mean it is it's
infuriating but again they're trying to
brush it under the road what time did
the fire start so it was about
mid-afternoon
uh and so that's why that's why a lot of
these parents were at work they couldn't
get home to their children and schools
were closed why because the power was
out which goes back against Maui County
government's argument them saying that
oh well the fire started because in the
and the lines were alive when the fire
started that could be why the power's
out right well because they shut the
power down lines went down started a
fire yeah they shut the power down so
three o'clock in the morning the night
before is when the power or when the
lines started going early that morning
yes so we're talking so there was a 10
hour difference and then one of the
brush fires started about one uh 1 p.m
okay so we're we're talking 10 hours
here
and
so and then they said that 1pm brush
fire was 100 contained they sent the
firefighters to another part of Maui uh
takula uh which is probably about 45
minutes away Two fighter fire out there
so there were no firefighters for the
most part in except for off-duty ones
that were in Lahaina at that point that
hundred percent contained fire ended up
spreading ferociously throughout the
town there was no water there were no
firefighters what are you gonna do about
it
so I I my guess is I would have went
into the ocean I mean it's not like I
did see a video of people that went into
the ocean and survived 10 hours in the
standards during smoke too yeah so the
smoke inhalation could still get you I
mean that was the crazy thing watching
these videos of people standing in the
water and they are in a cloud of smoke
so it's possible that some of the
missing people older people yes there
are a lot of people that have died
washed away in the water yeah because
you pass out you're in the water you
pass out from smoke inhalation you're
gonna drown because you're gonna fall
down you're in the water and then you
get washed away and people don't find
you they will not find you they and
they're trying they are actually down
there there is a big search effort in
the water still to this day uh from the
day that I left I was there three days
ago I'm going back this week uh and they
have a huge search effort in the water
but the death count still hasn't gone up
because they're not finding any bodies
in there they know people died in the
water this is the this is the problem
with uh chicken ranch government chicken
Nanny State governing or chicken ranch
governing that the police say we know
it's best for you we won't inform you
about what's going on shut up and do as
you're told and then you die which
Hawaii has had very intensely probably
always but definitely in the last couple
years with covet they had some of the
most intense code restrictions and
therefore had a tested how compliant
their population was I'm curious I don't
know if you can speak this but what's
the reaction from the islands around it
I mean like do the other communities
kind of pair it the same lines as you
know Lahaina did the best they could or
are they critical of how Lahaina managed
the fires so it's actually very it's a
very polarizing issue out there uh they
most people even a lot of the the
democrat-leaning people that I've spoken
with out there are like this is a this
was a catastrophic failure of government
you know the people that they voted for
they have totally lost faith in these
people uh these people got very
comfortable the mayor especially uh and
the governor of Hawaii both both very
liberal Democrats they got very
comfortable out there they thought
because it's a very blue State uh and
even the people that are typically their
voter base are now questioning whether
or not that's a that's a good decision
because they've gotten way too
authoritarian
and there's no sign of that going back
they are right now they are putting so
much pressure
on the people to try to maintain that
power maintain that grip on the
narrative that a lot of people are
waking up and that's honestly that's not
due to the name the mainstream media
that's due to Independent journalists
that are calling them out
I I keep thinking about how the cops
stopped people on the road where they
burned to death alive obviously they
were alive if they died but uh that's
the most I mean it's not like Soviet
lockdown because they weren't throwing
them in gas Chambers but like they held
them in a gas chamber yeah
that's the banality of evil yeah right
the idea that the individual cops didn't
think they were doing anything wrong
they thought they were doing something
good but in fact they are responsible
for the death of all these people if the
cops were not there
some people may have uh run over power
lines I mean who knows but a lot more
people would have just driven Out of
This Disaster Zone and survived well I'm
sorry I cover disasters that's what I do
okay I've covered tornadoes I've covered
hurricanes you can drive over live power
lines okay just don't you know don't
speed over it why
why can you drive over or why why is
faster worse well because I mean you you
risk shooting that that line up into the
frame of your vehicle and you don't want
to do that a live one thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time